Julie Stout: I think we are good to go. So today is March 9th, 2026. My name is Julie Stout, and I'm here with Richard March, or Rick March, and I'm here in Bloomington, Indiana, and you are in…
Julie Stout: Portland, Oregon. Portland, Oregon, and it is around 6.30pm my time, but it's 3.30 your time, Pacific time, correct?
Julie Stout: Great. Yes. So, we are here for part two of this oral history interview, and I really wanted to dive into the Dorsen Gary project in particular, if you are all good to go.
Rick March: Yes?
Julie Stout: So, just to dive right in, I want to talk about your first involvement with the project. How did you first become connected to the Dorson Gary project? When, where, and in what capacity?
Rick March: Well, it was, you know, I'd finished 2 years of the graduate program and gotten my master's.
Rick March: And, so this was, 1975.
Julie Stout: At IU, correct?
Rick March: Excuse me?
Julie Stout: At IU?
Rick March: At IU, yeah, I only went to the grad program at IU.
Rick March: And, and I,
Rick March: you know, Dr. Dawson, who I'd taken classes from and so forth, and, you know, we were well acquainted, you know, called me in to his office and, offered me the,
Rick March: You know, research assistantship.
Rick March: Dawson liked to divide up his assistantships that he had available into half-assistantships and so forth, but I was more fortunate than many of the grad students who
Rick March: I had the research assistantship, and then I was also offered a teaching assistantship, so each of them were… each of them were a half
Rick March: assistantship, so I had the full amount of money coming in. The assistant… the teaching assistantship was for, Mary Ellen Brown's, folklore… I believe it was called 1A, the Intro to Folklore.
Rick March: At that time.
Rick March: And there were about, oh, I don't know, 6 of us that were the TAs.
Rick March: And, you know, I learned, through the process of, you know, talking to Dorsen, talking to the other students, there were initially about, oh, I don't know, 6 or so of us that were going to be in the project in Gary.
Rick March: He made it… Clear to me, because,
Rick March: I think, yeah, I had done a… I had done a paper…
Rick March: That involved, field work in my mother's home village.
Julie Stout: And.
Rick March: I did it actually for a course with Henry Glassie, but anyway, it was… it was known that I was fluent in Servo-Croatian, as we called it then, and he had…
Rick March: Dr. Dawson said that he had previously done some initial field work in the Calumet region, as we called the section of northern Indiana and the joining section of southeast Chicago into Illinois.
Rick March: he had done a little work, and he had been intrigued, particularly by the Serbian community there.
Rick March: And, you know, he's aware there's also a Croatian community, so, you know, he… he offered me the assistantship, and I thought, wow, okay, this sounds good, this sounds interesting. And,
Rick March: We… we had some initial meetings, and it was pointed out that the,
Rick March: It was pointed out that the NEH grant was from a program that was designed to have academics, create,
Rick March: curriculum materials, AV curriculum materials, and that sounded exciting. And initially, there was one of my fellow grad students who's a little farther along in the program than the rest of us, and she was,
Rick March: a filmmaker, but,
Rick March: She didn't wind up sticking with it because as it became apparent, the kind of budget for film, for using, you know, especially color film in those days, was gonna be beyond what the grant could support, and we…
Rick March: You know, opted to get, you know, what was then very new, videotape equipment.
Rick March: It was, at a time when,
Rick March: the equipment was quite bulky. We had, we had great big cameras and, and, and had to have a, a strap over our shoulder with a big,
Rick March: you know, reel-to-reel deck that was much bigger than an audio reel-to-reel dick. So we were, you know, when we eventually got those and were in the field, we were pretty obvious, we were pretty visible.
Rick March: So, in fact, I… I… I wrote a paper
Rick March: that there was a student-created journal called Folklore Forum.
Rick March: They're probably in the library there. I'm not sure how many years it went on. I was one of the people that was in the… on the founding year. And, it was about the second or third year of it that I wrote a paper called How I Became the TV Man.
Rick March: Because, you know, there were some occasions when there were kids that had spotted me in the neighborhood, you know, carrying this thing, and they said, oh, it's the TV man, it's the TV man!
Julie Stout: Was it that bulky? Like, can you… do you have, like, an estimate of, like, the size of the.
Rick March: Let's see, the camera… the camera itself was probably about maybe 18 inches long.
Julie Stout: What's terrible about that.
Rick March: 6 inches wide, and it had a… it had a microphone with a sponge cover, you know.
Julie Stout: On the top of it? On the top of it.
Rick March: And then… and then the,
Rick March: Oh, I would say that… let's see…
Rick March: Yeah, the tape deck was… boy, oh boy. You know, something similar in terms of maybe 18 inches by 18 inches by, you know, it was big and cubic and,
Julie Stout: Early.
Rick March: heavy.
Julie Stout: Yeah, yeah.
Rick March: At that time, TV news people were going around, and they had even more bulky things, because they could do color.
Rick March: And, they had to roll them around in, kind of, shopping cart-like,
Julie Stout: Mmm…
Rick March: All, everything except for the camera around.
Rick March: Yeah, so, so, the,
Rick March: The thing that I… that I realized pretty quickly is that Dr. Dawson had pretty minimal interest himself in the… in the AV aspect of it.
Rick March: You know, he had, authored, you know, something like, two and a half dozen books at that point, and was very proud of the fact he was the, you know, author of more than 30 books.
Rick March: And, he wanted to write a book, which ultimately came out as, you know, Land of the Millrats.
Rick March: And, You know, that was, that was,
Rick March: you know, his main emphasis. And so it was… it was… it was left to me and, another guy who was pretty enthusiastic about the AV aspect, was brought in, a guy named Tom Adler.
Rick March: And, so he did some work on that, and, you know, John Hassey was interested in getting, you know, some of the gospel music in African American churches documented using the video. But, oh, the other thing I should say is that
Rick March: One of the ways that this project was kind of considered pioneering in the United States is that
Rick March: There hadn't been these kind of joint research projects where, you know, scholars with several
Rick March: emphasis, you know, somebody that was an, you know, music emphasis, like, like me, or ethnic, or somebody that was, you know, oral literature emphasis, like Phil George with, he had Spanish knowledge, I had, Turbo Croatian, that, you know.
Rick March: Dawson, recruited, you know, several scholars with differing areas of… areas of specialty that would
Rick March: you know, be useful in the, you know, ethnic communities of, the Calumet region.
Rick March: And while this had been
Rick March: a normal practice at, European, you know, folklife research institutes, where they would, they would decide… of course, they usually, you know, unlike anthropologists, they… they usually did their research in their, in their,
Rick March: home country, and they would say… they would have planned out, you know, in meetings, oh, we're going to go to Region X.
Julie Stout: This year, and and…
Rick March: people would go in larger or smaller teams, together. So this hadn't really been the practice at all in the United States, which was still very much, you know, on an individual basis.
Rick March: So, you know, that was an important innovation, in a sense, by,
Rick March: doing this in the U.S. And also, of course, it was still controversial whether, it was the provenance of folklorists to study in the city. And, you know, there were arguments that, oh, no, that should be, sociologists who study.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: in the city, So, you know, in those ways, the Gary project was kind of pioneering.
Rick March: So, you know, it was… it was exciting to be part of it, and I had… I had a…
Rick March: A little VW Beetle car, you know, at the time, and
Rick March: when I, you know, had a… I mostly went up on weekends, or, you know, if I didn't have classes every day of the week, you know, sometimes long weekends.
Rick March: And…
Rick March: You know, the… there was a travel budget, which was cool. They, you know, paid my gas mileage to and from, I'm thinking, what was it, about maybe a 3-hour drive up to, to Gary from Bloomington?
Julie Stout: That sounds about right, yeah.
Rick March: Yeah, so it was about a 3-hour drive, and one of the first people that I met was…
Rick March: the father of my brother's student. Now, so my brother taught Slavic languages at the University of Kansas in Lawrence.
Rick March: And there was a student from Gary who, you know, went to the university there and took his Turbo-Croatian language class.
Rick March: And, she told him… my brother, she told him about… my brother's named William March, incidentally.
Rick March: that her father, her name was Karen Opacic, and her father, Milan Opicic, was a tambourica maker and player, and
Rick March: He made these instruments that are, string instruments that range in size from, like, smaller than a mandolin to as big as a stand-up string bass.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: It's, like, 5 different sizes.
Rick March: And, he, in addition to making instruments, was,
Rick March: a member of one of the popular combos that played that music at events, you know, in both the Serbian and Croatian ethnic community, and maybe sometimes at, like, there was an international
Rick March: holiday folk fair or something, and, you know, groups from various ethnic groups would play. So, they, they, you know, it was a, it was a pretty good little, little sideline. Milan was a firefighter.
Rick March: who, worked for the city of Gary, in one of the downtown firehouses, and at that time, firefighters
Rick March: worked 24 hours straight, and then they had 48 hours off. You know, it's kind of the equivalent of having 8 hours straight, and then 16 off if you worked, you know, in a 24-hour cycle, so you worked a 172 hours straight cycle.
Rick March: And,
Rick March: On the two days that he didn't have to go into the firehouse, he had a very well-equipped
Rick March: Workshop in his, in his, garage.
Rick March: A lot of power tools and, you know, various woodworking equipment. He had recently moved to that area, Sharerville, Indiana. Previously, he had lived in a neighborhood of Gary called Glen Park, which was on the south side of the city of Gary, but a lot of the Slavic people were moving
Rick March: further to the south, to more suburban locations, you know, is a typical urban situation where, African Americans were, moving into new neighborhoods, and then there would be this white flight, and people moving out, and…
Rick March: So, yeah, he had just really, only some months before I met him, moved into that…
Rick March: It was in Cherville. And he proved to be a really important, informant for me, because he knew everybody.
Rick March: You know, as a, you know, he knew all the people associated with the music tradition, because they came to have instruments repaired, or they needed to buy a set of instruments for a youth orchestra, or they needed to hire his band to play for a wedding, an anniversary, whatnot.
Rick March: And, It, it, it quickly spread so that I met,
Rick March: you know, a whole array of people in the Serbian and Croatian communities, and…
Rick March: And, what Dr. Dawson was interested in.
Rick March: You know, one of the things that made it clear, you know, he was… he was aiming for this book, Milan told this really charming story about
Rick March: when he first started to make instruments, that it was common to make a tambaritsa with the back of the instrument made out of a turtle's shell, you know, a big, like, snapping turtle.
Rick March: And, you know, then, you know, wood would be fitted on, you know, so it'd have kind of a rounded turtle shell back, and then you'd fit wood over the top, and it had a neck and strings.
Rick March: So, he had a brother, actually a half-brother.
Rick March: Whose name? I can't remember now.
Rick March: Who had… was an ex-Marine and had been a sharpshooter.
Rick March: And, they went out into a swampy area, so around the, you know, Kellumet region.
Rick March: you know, in the vicinity of Lake Michigan, there are lots of swamps,
Rick March: That, on the edge of the urban area. So they went out into a swamp looking for a snapping turtle.
Rick March: And, his sharpshooter brother, you know, saw a turtle, you know, raise his head up above the water's surface, and bang, he shot the turtle, and they had to go rushing out there and get it. And,
Rick March: you know, he told the story, the thing about turtles is that their nervous system and their brain isn't, so much connected, so that,
Rick March: although the turtle was killed, you know, its legs were still, you know, working. So anyway, they threw the turtle… I think they were in a rowboat or something.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: So they threw the turtle into the rowboat, and it was…
Rick March: crawling around, and it kind of creeped me a lot out.
Rick March: And, and,
Rick March: his brother, as a hunter, had a strict ethic that, you know, if you… whatever game you shoot, you have to eat, you know, you don't kill it just, you know, purposely.
Julie Stout: it, yeah.
Rick March: Yeah, so, so they had to prepare turtle soup, and his brother was talking about, oh yeah, they say the turtle, snapping turtle, tastes like 6 different kinds of meat, and, you know, whatever.
Rick March: And Milan said, oh, you know, that the legs were still wiggling around when they put it into the pot and everything, so it was, you know, he was grossed out by the whole thing. But, eventually he, he made the,
Rick March: The… the turtle shell-backed,
Rick March: Tom Borica. He had it for a number of years. He said he inexplicably sold it to somebody, but he managed to get it back.
Rick March: It traveled from one order to another, and he… once he got it back, he seemed more, really. He said, no, I'm not gonna keep this the rest of my life. So anyway.
Rick March: I played the recording that I had made on a, you know, we had cassette recordings in those days, you know, we
Rick March: So I, I,
Rick March: you know, played it in Dr. Odorsen's office for him, and he loved it. He thought it was just a terrific story.
Rick March: And… he insisted that I take him over to Milan's house.
Rick March: So, he could re-record the same story on his own
Rick March: tape recorder, so that it was collected by Richard M. Dawson, as opposed to collected by his student, Richard March.
Rick March: You know, and I said, oh, I kind of am starting to get the drift about this guy.
Rick March: And, so, you know, I, I,
Rick March: you know, mainly worked in those Slavic communities. One of the next guys I met, we went to a, a,
Rick March: a community event where a Serbian youth music and dance group was performing.
Julie Stout: And before.
Rick March: Before… before the big group, you know, performed with all, you know, 25 kids, you know, teenagers mostly.
Rick March: they had a guy who played a, traditional instrument called the goosele, which, all the Slavs play, and maybe you've heard about, you know, Singer of Tales and so forth from, Albert Lorde.
Rick March: And,
Rick March: So, you know, I… I went up to the guy and talked to him after he got off stage and arranged to come over to his house, and
Rick March: that's how I wound up making the video that is on YouTube, called A Singer of Tales in Gary, Indiana. His name was Voyslav Rykovich, actually, and
Rick March: We had, we had fun taping it in his kitchen, and there was one point at which the telephone rang and his wife had to walk
Rick March: through the camera, you know, to go get the phone. I think I decided to leave that in, because I wanted to… I wanted to emphasize, you know, the domestic aspect of how we were doing this, this fieldwork.
Rick March: So,
Rick March: You know, I… I did a… I did a… a thing on, comparing the… the… also the Tombaritza with the Goose Lay, and how the Tambarice has thrived in the U.S, but it's really rare to find people who play and people who appreciate the… the, you know, the…
Rick March: You know, to,
Rick March: people who are used to, you know, Western music, the harsh-sounding tone, And it's singing.
Julie Stout: Are you… are you still in touch with those people that you, interviewed and talked to?
Rick March: They've passed away. Milan died a few years ago. I was in touch with him for years, and.
Julie Stout: excuse me.
Rick March: Occasionally, if we were gonna be driving through the Chicago area, hitting someplace, like, oh, my mother-in-law lived in Florida, so from Wisconsin, I would try to time it. So, yeah, so I would try… I would let Milan know that I was gonna be passing through town, and we'd have lunch together.
Julie Stout: That's awesome, I love that.
Rick March: Yeah, and and then the other thing that I continued to do, you know, because I ultimately… I ultimately did a doctoral dissertation on the Tamboritsa tradition, comparing the way in which it is practiced in the United States to how it's practiced in the homeland.
Rick March: was, you know, at the time I was doing research part, Yugoslavia.
Rick March: And, the,
Rick March: the remarkable thing about, you know, there was, at that time, an outfit called University Microfilms that you could order any doctoral dissertation from, and they would give you, you know, a, you know.
Rick March: essentially a Xerox version of it that was shrunk down a little bit and bound. You know, you could order any dissertation.
Rick March: And, I started to get, royalties.
Rick March: From them, because what I didn't know is that a lot of people who were in the Balkan folk dancing, you know, kind of enthusiasts circle had found out about my dissertation and were ordering it.
Julie Stout: Whoa!
Rick March: And nobody, nobody,
Rick March: that I spoke to said, I never heard of anybody getting royalties, and I said, well, I don't know, whatever. And then I… I went to a press, Lavica Publications in Ohio, and said.
Rick March: Hey, you know, you ought to think about publishing this, you know, it's selling, you know, just in this form, and
Rick March: what I didn't know is when I told them, you know, what, you know, when I'd gotten sent an invoice, you know, or a report on the royalties.
Rick March: You know, when they heard that number, they… they… they thought, oh, forget it, we're not going to publish this, it's already… it's already saturated the market. Anyway, so… so… let me… there goes the cost.
Rick March: I, I, I studied, you know, Tambaritsa,
Rick March: You know, both in, in the Indiana, Indiana Harbor,
Rick March: you know, Gary, South Chicago.
Rick March: You know, in that… in that whole area, there were, there were several groups, and, you know, I got good, documentation, was able to… to interview, you know, quite a few people, and it all fit into the Gary Project's mission. So, you know, there's…
Julie Stout: Would you, building on that, would you say that, because you were one of the six, like, students chosen by Dorsen, your primary responsibility was to do field work? Like, interview, photograph, that sort of thing? Is there anything else
Julie Stout: You want to say about that, in particular?
Rick March: That was the primary responsibility, but also, you know, I became interested in trying to figure out how to edit the raw footage that.
Julie Stout: Pretty good.
Rick March: taken, with the, video. And, we had two tape decks, but we didn't really have, you know, Dawson didn't have, us, the project, order an editing deck.
Rick March: So, it was possible, you know, if you see the videos on YouTube, you'll see that it's pretty crudely edited, but,
Rick March: you know, they actually were used in some, classrooms, you know, in Bloomington for folklore courses. You know, a few times, the ones that… I don't know, I would say that, you know, John Hassey and I, and, trying to remember who else…
Rick March: There might have been one or two more of the students involved in the project that actually produced an edited videotape.
Rick March: And, you know, tried to keep them short to be used in a classroom setting, you know, you want it to be maybe 15 minutes at the most, you know. It's just hard for a professor to use a half-hour thing, you know, in a class that's only maybe 45 minutes, or an hour and 15 minutes at the most, if it's a Tuesday, Thursday thing.
Rick March: So.
Julie Stout: What software did you use for editing?
Julie Stout: If you remember. I'm very curious.
Rick March: No, I don't. I don't think we actually…
Rick March: It was very much like, I'd start the, the,
Rick March: The, videotape running on one deck, and it was hooked up
Rick March: to the other one, and I would hit record on the other one, and tape a certain amount of it, and then stop it, you know, after as many seconds as I wanted on that particular clip, you know. So it was very crude. Yeah, there wasn't… you know, later on, I,
Rick March: I've done a lot of sound editing, a lot of audio editing.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: you know, and… my career, because I had many years of working in public radio.
Rick March: But, I actually never became, real adept at video editing. That's why I'm.
Julie Stout: It's quite difficult.
Rick March: Yeah. Yeah, that's why the young woman, Ame Hayashi, who,
Rick March: did the visuals for the Japanese vintage music thing that I sent you the links for.
Rick March: It was really crucial to me, because I… the learning curve for me, especially in my 70s, was just not going to be there.
Julie Stout: If the learning curve is already, large for me in my 20s, I can only imagine anything… anyone older than me would probably also struggle with it, too, I feel.
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, so anyway, the,
Rick March: you know, there were, there were some, some interesting, occasions. Now, Dr. Dawson had some pretty severe
Rick March: health issues during the time that the dairy project was going on. But he relentlessly drove himself, and when he'd find out about, for example.
Rick March: Okay, I'm gonna tell this story.
Rick March: We, he had learned that there was gonna be a big occasion for a…
Rick March: an anniversary of the founding of, St. Sava's Church, the main, Serbian church, in… that was still in Gary. There was another one in another town,
Rick March: Yeah, yeah. Okay, yeah, anyway.
Rick March: In one of the suburbs.
Rick March: But, so he, he, he was all fired up about wanting to, you know, go there and document it and, write about it.
Rick March: And, so we traveled up together. And, you know, he had problems, like, with his esophagus collapsing, and he had heart trouble, and, you know, it was…
Rick March: It was worrisome, you know,
Rick March: You know, being with him for hours, and we… we had this,
Rick March: really, low-budget motel that Dawson made his headquarters and our headquarters. It was right on the corner of Highway 30 and Broadway.
Rick March: And… he,
Rick March: most of the time, everybody stayed there. There were a couple of students later on who refused to stay there, and
Rick March: I went to, you know,
Rick March: you know, more of a chain-type, Holiday Inn type place, but anyway, this place didn't have telephones in the rooms. There was a phone booth, you know, outside.
Rick March: Y.
Rick March: And, so, you know, it was… it was inexpensive.
Rick March: Well, we were… we were getting ready to go
Rick March: down to, you know, downtown Gary to this…
Rick March: Big occasion, and he had let the organizers of it know that he was gonna come.
Rick March: And, his wife, Gloria was down in Bloomington, and he went out, I was waiting in the room, and he went out to the phone booth to call Gloria to just check in with her and let her know we were heading down there.
Rick March: And he seemed like a long time he didn't come back.
Rick March: And and then finally, you know, totally out of breath and staggering, he stumbled into the room.
Rick March: And,
Rick March: you know, he, said, oh, you know, I don't know, I think I, I think I may have fainted.
Rick March: And I said, oh gosh, you know, so first thing I did is I got him into bed, and I, you know, put a pillow under his feet to elevate his feet some.
Rick March: And then I, he said I should check.
Rick March: on the phone booth, and I… I went out to the phone booth, and the receiver was just dangling.
Rick March: You know, in there. And, you know, I got on the phone, and, you know, Gloria was still on the phone, you know, in a panic.
Rick March: And.
Julie Stout: Oh, and who is Gloria?
Rick March: Excuse me?
Julie Stout: Who is Gloria?
Rick March: Gloria was, his wife.
Julie Stout: Oh, okay, thank you.
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, his wife Gloria in Bloomington, was just in a panic, And she,
Rick March: You know, so I described the situation, and I said, you know, I've got him in bed, he's resting now, you know, I'm gonna just go myself to this event and record it, and, you know, and, you know, make sure that he… make sure that he takes care of himself, you know, after this.
Julie Stout: Hmm.
Rick March: And so she thanked me, and, you know, we hung up.
Rick March: So I went back into the room, and I said, okay, Dr. Dorsen, you know, I think, I think, you know, you, you better just, you know, rest, and I'll go down there and…
Rick March: And, you know, take care of the recording and doing the fieldwork.
Rick March: And, he refused.
Rick March: he insisted on going. He said, no, no, I'm gonna be all right, you know, just let me rest a little longer, and and you know, what can I do? You know, he's my professor, you know.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: I couldn't tell him, bad boy, don't do this.
Rick March: So… We,
Rick March: you know, eventually got him up, and, you know, he was, I drove, he was the passenger in the car, and we got down to the church, and you know, we… we were able to park close, relatively, and he got out.
Rick March: And we got to the, you know, the main… the main portals of the church, which is, of course, at the back of the, you know, what do you call that? The… the…
Rick March: you know, the… the… I don't know, the chapel, or whatever they called it. And there was a guy who was, you know.
Rick March: had been his contact who, you know, was expecting him, waiting right there by the doors. And… and as soon as he saw him, he says, oh, yes, doctor, you are here! And, he… he grabbed him by the hand.
Rick March: And led him down all the way to the front, to the very front pew.
Rick March: And this was an extra-long special liturgy that was going on, and most of the time during this liturgy, it was customary for the congregation to be standing.
Rick March: And so there he was, down where everybody could see him. I, you know, the guy didn't take me down, so I, you know, I stayed in the back. And there was, there was Dr. Dawson, you know, standing up.
Rick March: for… I don't know, over an hour.
Julie Stout: With his health issues!
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, yeah, he had, you know, and I said, oh my god, you know, he… he is gonna keel over and die right down there. You know, I… I was really worried about him.
Rick March: But, you know, he survived it, and you know, the ceremonies ended, and we went into the big church hall, where they had a dinner, and they had,
Rick March: They had a, you know, a head table where there were some priests, and there were, you know, some other officers of the church, and… and,
Rick March: And there was this point that,
Rick March: you know, Dorson must have arranged, where, you know, the Master of Ceremonies said, And today we have from Indiana University Dr. Richard M. Dawson, author of more than 30.
Julie Stout: More than 30 bucks!
Julie Stout: Were you only there with him because of the health issues, or because you were also working with these people?
Rick March: Well, yeah, I was working with the people, and a lot wasn't in English.
Rick March: So I hit…
Julie Stout: So you actually knew… okay.
Rick March: I would, I would, you know, some of the, some of the
Rick March: talking was in English, but most of it wasn't at this point, and so, you know, I had to tell them, okay, they're talking about this.
Rick March: not a full translation, but I would,
Julie Stout: Just, like, quick, like, tidbits.
Rick March: Yeah, I would say, you know, so, you know, I did that,
Rick March: you know, with himself. You know, there were numerous occasions when I had to travel with him, and, you know, his health condition was always somewhat on a banana peel.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: And and he just drove himself, because it was so important to him to, you know, get the research, and he wanted…
Rick March: You know, it wasn't, you know, as was demonstrated by him having to re-tape the same story, it wasn't adequate for him to let his students do the documentary work, and he would just look at it and evaluate it, and .
Julie Stout: Yeah, yeah.
Rick March: That apparently just did not fit into his model of how a folklorist proceeds.
Rick March: And, the, there were some bigger occasions, like when there was a parade locally, that he wanted
Rick March: You know, all of the grad students there to be either taking pictures or video or, you know, dealing with various aspects, you know, because it was a big event, and we'd.
Julie Stout: Hmm,
Rick March: So, you know, we'd usually then travel in, like, maybe 2 or 3 cars, and, and, you know, meet up there.
Rick March: you know.
Rick March: Yeah. And…
Julie Stout: And that kind of leads me into, like, my next question with Dawson, because I wanted to ask you about, like, the project goal and the scope, because I know that you mentioned that this project was kind of a pioneer project in the sense that multiple students had different interests and were focused on different, like, a theme or a group.
Julie Stout: And I wanted to ask you, what were the project's aims at the start, and how did that evolve through the project, in your perspective?
Rick March: Hmm, interesting.
Rick March: Definitely did evolve.
Rick March: You know, none of us had any idea what to expect when we, you know, arrived, in Gary and the neighboring towns.
Rick March: I, I think that,
Rick March: What emerged was… that…
Rick March: I think Dawson had in mind, you know, as his, as his, you know, was his, emphasis on, oral literature, you know, he, he was, he was hoping to find,
Rick March: tales that kind of, you know, had an Arna Thompson.
Julie Stout: Hmm.
Rick March: Yo.
Julie Stout: Like, the tail type index and everything?
Rick March: Yeah, tail type, or motif, index, you know, he was hoping to find things like that. But, you know, it became apparent, one, that, you know, that kind of
Rick March: how should I say, genre, narrative art was less common, and what was more common is just people's, way of expressing themselves in terms.
Julie Stout: of…
Rick March: stories that they would tell about, you know, experiences they were having, or their thoughts about this or that, and, you know, it wasn't that there weren't a lot of significant things. And so, you know, you wind up seeing in Land of the Millrats that, Dawson has much less of the kind of,
Rick March: You know, items that had a, you know, that were a set piece, and more just, you know, narrative.
Rick March: And, I think another thing that, that… changed was… The…
Rick March: The issue that, that became much more prominent because people talked about it a lot, especially at that time in the 70s, was crime.
Julie Stout: Mmm, crime lore.
Rick March: Yeah, so a lot of, of, of…
Rick March: you know, it was… it was a time, you know, there had been… there had been the, 1960s, Black rebellions in, you know, in the, in the urban ghettos, you know, there had been,
Rick March: you know, Dr. King's assassination, and you know, things like that. And, the…
Rick March: you know, the racial antagonism and the worry about crime and the white ethnics identifying crime, like, almost exclusively with African Americans, was, you know.
Rick March: something that was much stronger, at least, than I had anticipated.
Julie Stout: I remember… I remember one… one informant who…
Rick March: I… I don't want a name, actually, told me
Rick March: you know, they had been living in the, Glen Park neighborhood of Gary, which was a predominantly white area that middle-class blacks started to move into. And she says, oh, I have nothing against these,
Rick March: these, Black families that are moving in, buying houses, you know, they're… they're, they're, you know, fine people, you know, hardworking, etc. But once, you know, there got to be, a fair number
Rick March: of African Americans in the neighborhood, and walking around, going to the store, and this and that. Then, as she put it, that element from the ghetto was able to come up into our neighborhood, and unnoticed, you know, and you know, the crime went up.
Rick March: So, yeah, it was a difficult time sociologically in terms of, in terms of those issues. And, you know, it kind of, it kind of, you know.
Rick March: you know, Nixon had been elected, and he, he had,
Rick March: he had played upon… upon racial, you know, disharmony as part of his political strategy. You know, he,
Rick March: won the South… the southern states had been voting for what we called in those days Dixiecrats. They were Democrats, but they were, very much, you know, racially, unenlightened, shall we say. And,
Rick March: But, yeah, he had won, over to the Republican Party. And yeah, it was, it was, so that was, that was another thing that, you know, was kind of a, a surprise,
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: Just how intense that was.
Rick March: You know…
Julie Stout: How's the… oh, I'm so sorry.
Rick March: You just didn't see that in Bloomington, obviously.
Julie Stout: No, yeah, of course. It's a completely different, like, demographic. Well, not completely different, but… different… yeah.
Rick March: Different… Social demographics.
Julie Stout: setting, yeah. Exactly.
Julie Stout: And… I know that you just said that you…
Julie Stout: who didn't want to mention that informant, and that kind of led me to my follow-up question about consent during that time. How were ethical considerations such as permissions, confidentiality, or community care handled during that time in your field work, if at all?
Rick March: Yeah, we, we,
Rick March: We, we did, we did wind up, initially we didn't, but then it was pointed out that we should, and we got.
Julie Stout: In terms of, like, getting, like, consent, like, via paperwork, or, like, sign this? Yeah, we had that, we had little half-sheet things.
Julie Stout: That.
Rick March: that said, you know, sign this, that, you know, you have… this gives permission for it to be put into an archive, and used for educational purposes, and there were things you could check off to say, you know, I don't want it to be
Rick March: You know, made public for, you know.
Julie Stout: Hmm.
Rick March: 25 years, or, you know, there were… you had various things you could check off on the form. I don't know if those, you know, in the files of what remains from the Gary project, those are there someplace. It seems like they should be, but maybe.
Julie Stout: They're probably, they're probably sitting around somewhere in the folders.
Rick March: Yeah. Yeah, so we, we did, and and sometimes, you know, after the fact,
Rick March: Some of the people that I'd already established kind of a relationship with were… were kind of puzzled by me, you know, now wanting them to sign something.
Julie Stout: Right.
Rick March: And we're a little bit,
Rick March: suspicious, you know, what is this? You know, should I… you know, because, you know, generally, you know, people say, yeah, don't sign anything unless you're… consult a lawyer, or whatever.
Julie Stout: Right, right, right.
Rick March: And so, Yeah, we, we did, we did, need to, we need to get,
Julie Stout: what did we call them? Release forms, I think. Release forms, yeah.
Rick March: And, but,
Rick March: Yeah, there were a lot of, it was, you know, over, over the course of the, the, the two academic years,
Rick March: you know, I… I would go up to Gary,
Rick March: I don't know, 3 or 4 times a semester, you know, and you know, the other, the other thing, you know, long-distance telephone was a lot more expensive in those days, but there was something called
Rick March: I think it was called a Watts Line, or something, I don't know, W-A-A, Wide Area Telephone Service, that's it. Watts Line.
Rick March: And the university had that, and you could dial a special number that got you into the Watts line, so then you.
Julie Stout: Good talk.
Rick March: for a longer time to, people up in the Calumet region and not run up a huge phone bill.
Rick March: And, so, you know, the, again, the remarkable thing I, I,
Rick March: I mentioned to you in another, interview, maybe it was in the recorded part, that Adrienne Seward did a, did her fieldwork to a different state via telephone, and that was considered, at that time, you know, just
Rick March: You know, wow, that's weird, you know.
Julie Stout: So…
Rick March: Yeah, we, we didn't really, we didn't really consider,
Rick March: doing our official field work on the phone, but we set up things. Oh, yeah, I'm gonna come up, maybe this event or that event is happening, or yeah, I'm gonna be home, and I'm gonna have time on…
Rick March: And, and, you know, we'd chat, and I got more, background information, but, I don't recall ever hooking up a microphone to a telephone and recording.
Julie Stout: Gordon.
Rick March: conversation.
Rick March: So that's another thing that the technology of the day has changed. Now, you know, I talk to my son in Japan, and it's basically free. I use Facebook Messenger, you know.
Julie Stout: Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
Rick March: And…
Julie Stout: Oh, yeah.
Rick March: We couldn't do that in those days.
Julie Stout: No, of course. And…
Julie Stout: Technology was something, funnily enough, that Inta Carpenter, who is the project coordinator, as you know, she mentioned was one of the biggest challenges next to, like, the logistics that she had to handle on the back end.
Julie Stout: And I wanted to ask you about, what were the toughest hurdles for you that you dealt with during the project, whether that be logistical, or funding, or was it the tech again, or was it, like, working with your fellow grad students that you would like to share?
Rick March: I never had any big disagreement with any of the other grad student.
Julie Stout: Hmm.
Rick March: I had some, some differences, but, you know, we tended to… to go, okay, live and let live, that's the way he or she wants to do it.
Rick March: So, we were a pretty congenial group.
Rick March: The,
Rick March: when we were doing some of our, you know, we're working in pairs or threesomes, you know, we figured out, you know, who was gonna be, like, we went to this… we went to this lake where there was a… we thought it was really striking that it was called Lake George.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: And it, I don't know if it was a natural lake originally, or what, but it's, like, surrounded by all of these, you know, steel mills, and, you know, it was this, like, you know, horrible, you know, industrial, you know.
Rick March: wasteland. But there was a beach there, and there were all kinds of people from, you know, Gary and vicinity, you know, having… having a good time there, and so we thought, well, let's go to the beach and get people,
Rick March: You know, so…
Rick March: Actually, in the How I Became a TV Man article, one of the things that… that I realized when we were going places that wasn't to somebody's house or something where we made an appointment with an informant,
Rick March: that people would assume, you know, when they saw the TV camera coming down there, they would assume what issue it was. So, people were coming up and saying, hey, the lake stinks, they oughta clean it up, you know? You know, they assumed that that was the… why.
Julie Stout: What channel is it gonna be on? And I remember saying to this one, group.
Rick March: I said, well, you know, we're not with one of the commercial TV news stations, you know, some of this stuff conceivably would wind up on PBS. And I went, yeah, well, hardly anybody watches that PBS stuff. And then a kid who was about 12 years old said, oh, not me, I'm a big fan of Sesame Street.
Rick March: But, and when we were in downtown Gary doing, you know, kind of a similar thing,
Rick March: it was assumed, because the downtown was really hollowed out, and lots of empty storefronts, and, you know, businesses had fled already, they assumed that… what your opinion of the mayor, Richard Hatcher, was at the time. And, you know.
Rick March: You know, so people would come up and say, yeah, yeah, downtown's dead, you know, Hatcher, Hatcher ought to do something about it, you know, he's wrecking the town. And again, that was part of the,
Rick March: the racial issues, because I think Hatcher was the first African American mayor of Gary.
Julie Stout: Oh.
Rick March: And, and so,
Rick March: Yeah, surprisingly, there's a, like, a… there's a section that's incorporated into Gary called Miller Beach, and it was… it was completely a white area. It was a little bit separated away, and the previous mayor was from Miller Beach.
Rick March: was, Jewish, background.
Rick March: And, the,
Rick March: what could I say? So, so yeah, you might, you might check out the article if you can find Folklore Forum, how I became the TV man, and, that, that deals with some of that. So, you know, those were… again, those were things that…
Rick March: you know, we didn't anticipate that just by being in a certain place and, you know, having TV equipment, having video equipment, that there would be an assumption that a particular social issue in the local area was.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: Why we were there.
Julie Stout: Yeah, yeah.
Julie Stout: And… Along with the…
Julie Stout: technology itself. I meant to ask you a bit earlier, but that was your first time working with that equipment, wasn't it?
Rick March: Yeah, anybody's…
Julie Stout: Anybody's first time, and so that alone is probably a huge thing. You had to, like, learning curve and everything, and…
Rick March: That's right, that's right. There were things you had to learn, like, for example, on Zooming.
Julie Stout: You…
Rick March: You needed to zoom in all the way as far as you might be likely to zoom, and get focused at that point.
Julie Stout: And then…
Rick March: back off, because if you did it the other way, it would be, as you zoomed in, it would go out of focus. So there were various things like that that, you know, you had to kind of learn on the fly. Although, somebody that helped us some
Rick March: So Dr. Dorsen wanted to have a film made by professional filmmakers, so he hired… he hired a couple of filmmakers from Bloomington.
Julie Stout: Go up there.
Rick March: And they made this… you know, he ultimately… he liked to go to this restaurant called Jenny's.
Julie Stout: Yeah, Jenny's… the movie and everything.
Rick March: Yeah, so Larry Regan was the owner, and Jenny, I think, was his mother-in-law or something, and and, you know, it had, it had, you know, the guy I talked about, Milanopicic, and the other members of his.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: They were playing, and
Rick March: And there were some of the, you know, dancers and so forth who we knew from other… other things, and…
Julie Stout: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Rick March: We, we let people know
Rick March: that this, filming was gonna go on, and the place was packed. I heard people joking that, that, that Larry Reagan ought to get, get some, you know, get a movie camera and just say that he was making a movie, and…
Julie Stout: And then it brings all the.
Rick March: business.
Rick March: They're on more business, do his restaurant. But,
Rick March: You know, so they also gave us some tips on,
Rick March: You know, how to… how to frame a shot and, you know, you know, focus and different things.
Julie Stout: Yeah, yeah.
Rick March: But yeah, we were rookies. We were rookies at it.
Rick March: And, and, But, you know, this is before
Rick March: You know, it wasn't that many years later,
Rick March: Well, you know, maybe at the beginning of the 80s that these, you know, handheld camcorders became a consumer, item, you know.
Julie Stout: Oh, so not that… not that long after, then.
Rick March: Yeah, so it was… it was maybe… it was maybe 6, 7 years later that it…
Julie Stout: handheld and everything. Yeah, these, you know, mostly, like, made by Sony, I think. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Rick March: And, And, and people's expectations that you could get images, you know, immediately.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: Send it off to some lab to, you know, get the photos developed.
Rick March: So those, those were things, and, you know, you know, as I mentioned, Dawson was sometimes challenging to deal with because he, you know, we were concerned that he was pushing his, you know, his health.
Julie Stout: Mom.
Rick March: beyond his endurance. He was pushing him, you know, And,
Rick March: You know, he… he clearly had,
Rick March: you know, he… he, in part was using us to, to ease his way into, situations, you know, like he had a couple of African-American, participants, Gil Cooley and Adrian Seward.
Julie Stout: Right.
Rick March: We're able to,
Rick March: you know, be a liaison and get him into, easier into, into Black community, you know, connections.
Julie Stout: Mmm…
Rick March: And, you know, he ultimately did get his wish by, having… I forget who published, if it was University of Illinois Press, like most of his other books, but,
Rick March: He ultimately did get the land of the Millrats,
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: published.
Julie Stout: jump.
Rick March: And, we as grad students all Had a degree of…
Rick March: mixed feelings, about that. He did… he did mention us in there, you know, and so forth.
Julie Stout: You are in the book, you are in the book.
Rick March: Yeah, he did mention us, and so forth, but,
Rick March: You know, sometimes, sometimes we felt like, like, he, he was, you know, using us, you know.
Rick March: But, you know, I guess, I guess that's, particularly in that era, not uncommon for professors to have, you know, research assistants that,
Rick March: This supported the professor's work.
Julie Stout: Yeah, that… yeah, that's very fair. It's a fair assumption to make as well. And… It still happens today.
Rick March: Yeah? Yes.
Julie Stout: You mentioned Jenny's Cafe, in which Inta also mentioned she saw that as kind of a milestone of the project, because it was a huge deliverable that came out of the project, or the area, if you would.
Julie Stout: I wanted to ask you from your perspective, what pivotal events or decisions shaped the project's directions or outcomes that you can think of?
Rick March: Well, deciding to do it at Jenny's, you know, came out at a meeting where we were discussing, okay, we're gonna hire these filmmakers.
Julie Stout: Right.
Rick March: What ought to, you know, where should they go, and what should they do? And, you know, there were, there were a few other suggestions, but then, you know, just based on how much, multiple members of our team were familiar with the place, we went there to eat a lot.
Julie Stout: Yes, yeah, yeah.
Rick March: So,
Rick March: So I… and, you know, it was nice because we were able to include the foodways section, you know, as we showed.
Julie Stout: You're on.
Rick March: like the stuffed cabbage rolls, I think it was, and…
Julie Stout: Yeah, yeah.
Rick March: And, and, the…
Rick March: Yeah, you know, he really needed to get something, something deliverable for the NEH grant, and that was the main thing, because
Rick March: we didn't have adequate, editing, capacity to… Like to do that work, yeah. …the black and white, video.
Rick March: And,
Rick March: Although, you know, I'm glad that, you know, some of that, you know, has survived and is on YouTube to this day, some little chunks of it that, you know.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Julie Stout: And it's in IU Archives as well, the entire movie and the manuscripts for that and everything. People are able to view it today, which is really cool.
Rick March: Yeah.
Rick March: Yeah, so, I don't know, those were… And then,
Rick March: You know, right at the end of the school year of the project I had applied for and gotten a Fulbright and another kind of grant called an IREX, International Research and Exchanges, I got these two grants to go to Yugoslavia.
Julie Stout: Hmm.
Rick March: lobby a part of my, my, Tumbaritza fieldwork.
Rick March: and,
Rick March: So, you know, I was gone for over a year then, doing… doing that. It was nice because, you know, I'd previously, gone, you know,
Rick March: to Zagreb to study at the university, just on my own hook, and I.
Julie Stout: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Rick March: about, you know, don't you know people get scholarships? So now I had that.
Julie Stout: It was cool! During work and everything, yeah.
Rick March: I had, I had plenty of money to, you know, rent a comfortable, place, and, you know, yeah, it just,
Rick March: Yeah, do my work, and… the, Interview.
Rick March: when I, you know, when I came back, you know, Dr. Dorrison, I knew…
Rick March: you know, he had these… these things called dissertation clinics, where he was asking people to come in and bring in, you know, a chapter, and he'd analyze them, and, you know, and evaluate them, and give you some… some, you know, good advice. He was… he was a skillful writer of a certain type, you know, the…
Rick March: kind of, he did write for a more popular audience, wasn't heavy-duty, he didn't… coming out of the field of history, he didn't like the, social science, you know, jargony,
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: theoretical stuff.
Rick March: But,
Rick March: I… I decided when it was time… it was time to come back to the States, I had the…
Rick March: choose between going to Bloomington again, and going to, where my wife was from in Wisconsin.
Rick March: And,
Rick March: I opted for Wisconsin because, you know, I saw what often happened when people came back, and they were kind of at that stage where they've taken their prelims, they've done their research, they're in the process of writing, and
Rick March: you know, maybe, maybe get some kind of a small half of a research assistantship or something to, you know, to work for Darsen or Dave.
Julie Stout: Yeah, yeah.
Rick March: And… It… it seemed… it seemed pretty…
Rick March: I guess it sounds kind of harsh, but it seemed pretty humiliating to have to just sort of come back and then be doing this grunt work, basically for a professor, and I thought, now I'll go to… my wife, although she had actually grown up in Madison.
Rick March: She had a brother in Milwaukee, and she… to her, Milwaukee was a cool and interesting city, and Madison was, oh, yeah, that's as boring as where I grew up.
Rick March: everybody, everybody else would say, Madison's the coolest city, not Milwaukee, but whatever.
Rick March: So we moved… we moved to Milwaukee, and I managed to,
Rick March: piece together some… some part-time jobs. I work for Milwaukee Public Museum.
Julie Stout: on you.
Rick March: a folklore live series on Saturdays where I'd, you know, identify somebody who would come in and do a workshop of, you know, whatever, you know, traditional art they practiced, you know.
Julie Stout: Hmm.
Rick March: So that was… that was a kind of a cool job.
Julie Stout: I love that, yeah.
Rick March: Yeah, but then my… my mother job was for a community center in a neighborhood on the west side that
Rick March: It was identified with Puerto Ricans, because they were probably a larger ethnic group in the area.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: So there were still a lot of Irish, and one of the main Irish parishes was there.
Rick March: So, you know, I worked at Westside Community Center. The nice thing about them was that they would let me work full-time for a couple of weeks, and then have two weeks off, because I was doing contract work for.
Julie Stout: Oh, nice!
Rick March: on these various grants that, Bess Hawes was pitching a contract job my way. Somebody, you know, who had applied to do a folklore project, through the folk arts program, or the NEA, but didn't have a folklorist on their staff or.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: She insisted that they have to have a focal artist either working in the project, or at least consulting on it, and so…
Julie Stout: Mmm, yeah.
Rick March: I went to Utah and to Idaho, I went to Nevada. A lot was in that region, incidentally, that's kind of interesting.
Julie Stout: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Rick March: Partly it was because the people, you know, knew each other, and they said, oh yeah, this guy came in, and, you know, he did a good job for us. So,
Rick March: Anyway, you know, and I… wrote…
Rick March: as much of a completed manuscript before I went to see Dr. Dorset.
Rick March: You know, because I didn't want him,
Rick March: you know, picking it to death, you know, little by little, and I thought if I gave him, you know, a nearly completed manuscript, you know, there'd be some things that I'd need to revise at his suggestion. But, you know, it'd be less than if it was then piecemeal.
Rick March: So I waited, and it was until 1981 that I… I had this ready, and I drove down.
Rick March: And, you know, I gave him the big stack of manuscript that thick, you know?
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: And he was, he was excited about it.
Rick March: And I remember that, one of my, fellow grad students, Pam… yeah, what is her last name? Said, oh yeah, I saw Dr. Dawson, he was walking home with, with your, dissertation, saying, oh, he was just gonna finally have time to get around to plunging into it.
Rick March: And, you know, a week later was when he keeled over on the tennis court. You know, he had a heart attack, and he went into a coma.
Rick March: And he never came out of it. He died.
Julie Stout: in 1981.
Rick March: And, and I, I was,
Rick March: I was, at kind of a loss at what to do at first, because, you know, I had really written it along the lines that I knew he wanted,
Rick March: And another person on my committee was Linda Dag, and I knew she, you know.
Rick March: she didn't respect Dorsen's approach, and would have wanted a whole different thing, you know, using different theoretical approaches.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: And… and I thought, oh no, if I… if I make… dig the chair.
Julie Stout: Rewrite the whole thing.
Rick March: Yeah, I'll probably have to rewrite the whole thing. So, I'm… I asked Ilhan Bashkos, who was also on it. Ilhan, because he was an expert on Turkish folklore.
Julie Stout: And the time.
Rick March: Barica actually originally came out of the Middle East and was brought into the Balkans by the Ottomans.
Rick March: You know, he was a, a reasonable,
Rick March: you know, placement, and he told me, he said, well, you know, I know you wrote this for Dorsen, and that's fine, I just want you to write one chapter that's aimed at me, and, you know, he wanted me to write one that was on… he said, you know, you don't really have a chapter about the song lyrics, so, you know, write that for me, which I did.
Rick March: And what I didn't know is that,
Rick March: that Linda Daig was terribly insulted by the fact that I didn't pick her, and so it was… it was a… it was a difficult situation, and…
Rick March: Yeah.
Rick March: eventually, you know, eventually I was able, you know, Boschkos and Digg, hashed it out, and I scheduled a, defense for me, and I drove down from Milwaukee to Bloomington, and did the defense, and
Rick March: Ilhan took me to lunch, and he… he talked about, Some of the,
Rick March: you know, discard with… with Linda Dag, and… so, after… after the… I couldn't wait to… I thought I might stay overnight, you know, with a friend in Bloomington, and I thought, no, I'm getting the heck out of town!
Julie Stout: fair, yeah.
Rick March: So anyway, so anyway, my dissertation, you know, a huge section of it, the whole part that was
Rick March: focused on the United States, timber, it's a tradition in the United States, was, as a result of the Gary Project.
Julie Stout: I was about to ask you that, like, if you incorporated some of the fieldwork you did in Gary into it.
Rick March: Pretty much the whole… the whole thing, you know, that was… it enabled me, it enabled me to do all this fieldwork and, you know, meet all these musicians and, you know, get good, good data from them.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: And then, you know, I was able, when I was in Europe, to just concentrate on the European.
Julie Stout: The European side, yeah.
Rick March: And then, you know, there were certain… you know, actually, what I… what I wound up finding out
Rick March: was that there were many more similarities between the American and European traditions than I had expected.
Julie Stout: I thought.
Rick March: that the American tradition was a lot more organized, where, you know, the, you know, like an organization, Croatian Fraternal Union, Serb National Federation, you know, would sponsor a youth group and hire, you know, a.
Julie Stout: Future.
Rick March: And there'd be lessons, and there'd be, you know, learning materials brought in, and so forth. And I thought that was more of an American.
Rick March: thing, and when I got to Europe, I found that it was very much the same. There had already been a tradition of, you know, I thought I was… I had some romantic ideas that I was gonna find more, you know, you know, isolated peasants off, you know, doing pure folklore, as we thought.
Rick March: You know,
Rick March: But, so that actually was one of the conclusions that, that, you know, people who participate in a tradition utilize whatever,
Rick March: meetings of getting… getting information on the stuff. If there's records, they'll get… they'll buy records. If there are, you know, ways of… other ways of communicating, if they go to… if they go to festivals where they see other groups, they'll borrow stuff that they hear that they like from other groups at the festival, and, you know.
Julie Stout: God.
Rick March: And, so, yeah, it was… I think that, you know, one of the things my dissertation did was it demystified, some of those notions, and,
Rick March: Anyway, and, then, I…
Rick March: I had the opportunity… after that outfit in Ohio turned me down about publishing it, I didn't bother to try for a long time until I went to a festival. I brought some native, tribal people from Wisconsin to this International Folk Festival in Zagreb.
Rick March: And, one of my colleagues from the,
Rick March: institute that I had worked at there at Zagreb said, why did you never publish your dissertation?
Julie Stout: And I said, well.
Rick March: I don't know, I mean, I did try once, and it got turned down, and it just wasn't something that I needed to do for my job as the state folk art specialist in Wisconsin. It wasn't… so I just never did anything. He said, well, you know, if you…
Rick March: Rewrite it and bring it up to date, we'll publish it.
Rick March: And so I said, oh, okay, well, that'll be great.
Rick March: And,
Rick March: As things worked out, they had some budget cuts and this and that, and they weren't able to publish it.
Rick March: You know, she helped me actually stay on track by.
Julie Stout: a.
Rick March: I was sending her revised things, and she was, her name was,
Rick March: Naila, Terebasic. And so Nyla had, you know, helped me with, editing. And…
Rick March: And then, you know, when it was clear that they weren't going to be able to do it, they didn't have the funds to have it translated from English into Croatian. And she said, well, why don't you just get it published in the U.S? So I took it to the University of Wisconsin Press, and they accepted it.
Julie Stout: Hmm.
Rick March: Oh, wow.
Rick March: So anyway, so another thing that came out of, you know, massively from my work in Gary was not only the dissertation, but also kind of the first book published in the United States in English that dealt with that tradition.
Julie Stout: Covers that, yeah.
Rick March: Yeah, so yeah, the Tombaritza tradition, you know, UW Press, you can take a look at
Rick March: You know, you know, their website and see what they…
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: the… I think the, I think that the hard copy is already… you know, books are so much like fresh bread, and after, you know, about 5 years or 6 years, they… they go, oh, well, you know, we don't want to store them at the, you know, warehouse in Chicago anymore, and they… they cut them.
Rick March: Yeah. But they keep, they keep the, the e-book version available.
Rick March: I think it's only available as e-book now, and the same thing.
Julie Stout: Okay, yeah, it's worth looking into, for sure.
Rick March: And…
Julie Stout: It's clear that the Gary Project impacted your career, like, academically, and then later as a public folklorist.
Julie Stout: And so my…
Julie Stout: Like, almost, like, wrapping up question for you is continuing on the… on the impact and legacy and reflecting on it.
Julie Stout: What were other lasting impacts that stand out to you for participants, for IU, and the field itself, and what lessons or advice would you pass on to future stewards?
Julie Stout: A bit of a dense question, so answer…
Rick March: I think that the,
Rick March: The experience of doing the group field work in, you know, an urban setting, and
Rick March: Was the start of my…
Rick March: Moving away from wanting to be strictly on the academic, you know, the track.
Rick March: I… I felt,
Rick March: one of the nice things about it is that, you know, I realized in the way I was interacting with people that,
Rick March: you know, there was kind of an assumption in the older folkloristics that the folklorist was operating on a totally, in a totally different existential reality from the informant, and that they wouldn't understand your stuff, and, you know, but…
Rick March: you know, what I found, you know, in an American urban environment was, you know, people who were knowledgeable and knew how to navigate… they didn't maybe know a lot of details about the way academic, you know, systems worked, but… but, you know, I…
Rick March: I realized that… that this notion that the people that we were, you know, documenting were, you know, so… so different from, you know, ourselves, was… was false. That,
Rick March: And, you know, I'd ask them what they thought of, you know, I said, you know, I would be able to say, you know, what I hear you telling me is this. Is that a correct interpretation? And they'd say, well, yeah, but, you know, it's more like this, a little bit. You know, so, you know, their knowledge
Rick March: their, intellectual knowledge, I came to appreciate more. And then also, that… you know.
Rick March: our… I got to thinking more in terms of, what were these communities' desires in terms of
Rick March: Having their traditions documented, it may be archived, it may be presented in various formats, either media formats or, you know, to organize an event, a festival, or this or that.
Rick March: And, it appealed to me to be somebody Would be a resource person.
Rick March: to… you know, communities that practice the traditional art. And, that's why, you know.
Rick March: when I was living in Milwaukee, and, you know, I was teaching some part-time, things, and I… I got… I got a couple of, adjunct
Rick March: courses to, you know, I taught,
Rick March: I taught some folklore at University of Wisconsin-Milwaukee campus. But, you know, in those days.
Rick March: They gave you $2,000 flat, and you taught a course.
Rick March: And then I told them when they wanted to rehire me after the second year, I said, well, you know, I can't do it unless I get a, you know, like, a partial appointment or something, or, you know, and so the guy in the ethnic studies program, it was.
Rick March: He said, well, how about if we give you $3,000? And I said, no, I just… I just can't do it.
Rick March: So, you know, the opportunities were beginning to appear, because Bess Hawes wanted to get a state folk arts coordinator in every state. I was once in Washington, and,
Rick March: on a panel, and there was a grant that came up that I had a conflict of interest. It was, you know, like a Wisconsin applicant, and so, you know, you had to recuse yourself. So you left the little conference room, and usually we went and we sat at Bess's
Rick March: desk, because it was vacant while she was in the little room. So I noticed she had a map of the U.S.
Rick March: You know, the type of map that has all the states in different colors so that they stand out.
Rick March: And she had… She had, pushpins with the little round knobs on them in different colors.
Rick March: in, you know, the states where there was a state folk arts specialist, and in Wisconsin, there was mine, and it was red.
Rick March: And I, and I said, oh!
Rick March: oh, now I really understand, you know, we're part of this cadre that Bess was trying to create to influence, you know, cultural policy.
Rick March: In the country, and it was great to be part of that team, and that's what led me to, you know, trying to bring… bring all the state coordinators together at the National Assembly of State Arts Agencies, and so forth. So,
Rick March: I think,
Rick March: you know, the Gary… the Gary project was the germ of… of… of thinking along those lines. And, you know, I… I… I think that,
Rick March: you know, I guess it's over 50… well, exactly 50 years, kind of in the middle, yeah. The start of it is a little over 50, and…
Rick March: I think that, you know, whatever documentation is there has value in terms of people looking back to see how things have changed or not changed over 50 years. And, you know, I hope they're archived well, and
Rick March: I don't know what it takes to get scholars to be aware of it, to come there and poke around and use it as a resource for their research.
Rick March: I know at the Mills Music Library in Madison, the university has you know, put…
Rick March: you know, bits of it on, on their online. You know, not everything is, is,
Rick March: digitized, and not everything is… that is digitized is online, but they're… they're continually… they're continually increasing that, and I suspect, you know, in your… the other half of your… your, your identity.
Rick March: That's, that's a direction that's really important.
Rick March: In terms of, you know, archives being more accessible, you don't have to, you know.
Rick March: Buy a plane ticket, and get a hotel room, and then go someplace and put on white gloves, and, you know.
Julie Stout: thing.
Rick March: Yeah, that is… it's just changing, and I, I think that that's, the, the,
Rick March: You know, original… the original documents, ought to be preserved, you know, they… once they get digitized, you shouldn't, you know.
Rick March: haul them out to the shredder, you know? But, the,
Rick March: The digitized and then the online versions are, you know, going to be increasingly important and increasingly used in people's research.
Julie Stout: Regarding the fieldwork portion of your work on the Gary Project.
Julie Stout: What do you wish you knew before starting your fieldwork, and what advice would you give to students who want to engage in future fieldwork themselves?
Rick March: Yeah, I,
Rick March: it took me a little while to gather that, that the knowledge and opinions of the people. You know, the whole word informant is, is problematic in some ways, and I'm not sure what you can replace it with. There probably are a few terms, but,
Rick March: you know, there was… there was that, that I, again, would have liked to have had a… a firmer grasp of, I can do this, the work in this project in partnership with the people that I'm supposed to study.
Rick March: You know, that was… that was, important.
Rick March: I think I was… I was really lucky, luckier than many, in that the bulk
Rick March: of the research I did was, you know, in a culture that was very familiar to me. You know, my mother was born in Croatia, and I, you know, spoke the language, and I actually have Serbian relatives, too. One of my aunts married a Serbian, and they go to the Serbian church. And so.
Rick March: you know, it was… it was people that I felt
Rick March: You know, the whole issue of doing research in your own community, that came up with Elena Brodunes as well. She did some research on the Lithuanian community, which she was a part of.
Rick March: And,
Rick March: I think she wrote an article, maybe it was in that Folklore Forum thing, about working with your own, you know, your own ethnicity, and what are issues with that.
Rick March: But,
Rick March: I think that, you know, for someone like John Hassey, who was, you know, had very little
Rick March: personal contact with African Americans before the project. You know, it was probably a really, really big growth experience, and, you know, he ultimately had this great career working primarily with jazz and jazz musicians at Smithsonian, and
Rick March: So, you know, I, I, I think,
Rick March: I think that the project, you know, it offered, you know, differing kinds of growth opportunities for all of us grad students who were involved.
Rick March: And… and we also had to learn how to, navigate Dr. Dawson's…
Rick March: peculiarities, I guess I'd have to say, you know? I mean, I'm trying… I'm not trying to slam him, you know, he was a very congenial fellow and all that, but, you know, he… he had… he had his blind spots in a number of areas, and
Rick March: you know, I'm grateful that, you know, this opportunity was pitched my way, and it was 2 years of, you know, a fulfilling and, you know, a fulfilling experience, I guess.
Rick March: Yeah, and like I said, some of the people, just a few of them, I've stayed in touch with, you know, for the rest of their lives. Most of the informants were older than me, and, you know, I'm gonna turn 80 in December, so if, you know, if they were
Rick March: 5 years older than me, they might…
Rick March: Some of them are still alive. Most of them were, you know, 10 or more years older than me, and they've passed on.
Julie Stout: What, what advice would you give, then, to students? Open mind,
Julie Stout: I don't know, what, based on your experience, what would you say?
Rick March: Yeah, I, I think, I think that the crucial thing is, to,
Rick March: you know, when you… when you go into an unfamiliar setting, and with people that you don't know, that you're careful to explain just what you're all about, and you don't seem to make promises that you can't keep, like, oh, this is gonna be on TV, or whatever.
Rick March: you, our,
Rick March: if they're curious about you, it's fine for you to spend time explaining, yeah, okay, yeah, I was born in Chicago, and I grew up on the blah blah blah, and then, you know, that was all…
Rick March: You know, just promoting that kind of personal equality between yourself and the people that you're doing research with.
Rick March: I think that that's, you know, really key, and…
Rick March: I had… I… I think I… I think I mentioned, you know, my… with my job as the State Focal Arts Specialist for Wisconsin, I had a tremendous number of people that… that, you know, I…
Rick March: worked with and became close with, and some… when I… when I announced I was going to retire, I retired at age 62, because I was really ready. I wanted… I had 3 books in mind that I wanted to write, and
Rick March: we were having, you know, our agency's budget cut, we were, you know, facing a lot of political pressures, and I said, okay, I can get out and let somebody else have the job.
Rick March: And, but… that… when I… when I was…
Rick March: some people organized a retirement party for me, and they held it at… there's this… there's this building in, Madison called the Labor Temple. It's a… it's a building that has a lot of offices that various unions, rent, and then there's a big ballroom that, you know, for events.
Rick March: And so we had my retirement party at the labor temple, and people kept me out of, you know, the planning and everything. They said, you know, no, no, no, Mark, you know, I mean, I knew it was gonna happen. And I was… I was flabbergasted. Something like 200 people came.
Rick March: I… I was… I was flabbergasted, and you know, everybody from,
Rick March: you know, Black Gospel, quartet to, people from the, the tribes. The, the,
Rick March: guy from the Redcliffe Ojibwe Tribe, gave me the main gift for the event, which was a Pendleton blanket, and, you know, presented it to me, and,
Rick March: that, you know, receiving a gift, receiving a gift like that from a tribe, the blanket's a very significant thing. So, you know, I think, you know, my advice is, that, you know, working, working, you know, in public folklore.
Rick March: can be, you know, very, very rewarding. I had a friend who was the,
Rick March: the State Folk Art Specialist for Idaho.
Rick March: And he hired me on a contract job for a while. You said porn. Anyway, he wound up, accepting an academic job at Utah State University, and I ran into him at a conference, and we started talking, and he said that he really missed
Rick March: the camaraderie that we had as public folklorists. He said that, you know, in academic folklore, although occasionally there are collaborations.
Rick March: The bulk of what you're doing is individual work for yourself, And,
Rick March: And, you know, we often, you know, because of a lack of resources, we would try to figure out, oh, can we establish a regional project where we can get, you know, like, for example, we created a thing called the Midwest Folklife Festival.
Rick March: And it involved, 3 states, Minnesota, Iowa, and Wisconsin.
Rick March: Later Minnesota had to drop out, and then Illinois joined. And then, you know, we were able to… we were able to…
Rick March: You know, rotate this event. You know, every third year, your state would sponsor, you know, find a location, and… and, so, you know, it was great to just be collaborating with the people in the equivalent job in the neighboring state.
Rick March: And then, in,
Rick March: 1998, it was the sesquicentennial of Wisconsin statehood. You know, they became a state in 1848, so it was 150 years.
Rick March: And, among other things.
Rick March: we were invited to present at the Smithsonian Folklife Festival, a state program, and I, you know, again, because it was a big occasion, I managed to get, like, $600,000 out of the state legislature, which, you know, and…
Rick March: 28 years ago was… felt like more than it is now.
Rick March: And then, various businesses and so forth also contributed. And, you know, we had a really, a really outstanding program at Smithsonian, and the 140-some people that I was able to take there
Rick March: That experience of going there.
Rick March: was, you know, just a life-affirming experience. They all, you know… you know, that's why they were showing up at my retirement party.
Rick March: Then, you know, we had the,
Rick March: cultural exchange program with, Chiba Japan.
Rick March: And so everybody who got to go on that, again, that was a lifetime experience, you know, particularly for people who were of, you know, lower income, like the Black Gospel Group.
Rick March: that they would get to go to Japan and perform in Japan, and the press there was fascinated with them, and they got their picture and an article, you know, in Japanese newspapers, all written and stuff they couldn't read, of course, but, you know, they got the picture.
Rick March: So… It's…
Rick March: You know, I guess, I guess what I'm saying is that, that the Gary Project led me into… was a step in the direction of public folklore, and that public folklore was a fulfilling career, and I,
Rick March: you know, we're in a political environment where, you know, the NEA is suffering cuts, and, you know, what we do in terms of wanting to promote the cultural diversity and inclusion of those cultures in the wider American narrative.
Rick March: is… is not…
Rick March: supported by our current government. We can't be, dissuaded from continuing that. We can't, we can't say, oh, we're, we're gonna, we're gonna cut everything that involves people of color or something from our programs, or, you know, we, we, you know, just can't… that's just too unethical, and…
Rick March: And I think, you know, there aren't really any folklorists who are tempted to go that way. We just have to keep plugging along, and, you know, some people may lose jobs, and some people will retain them, and we have to hope for a resurgence at a later time.
Rick March: You know, so… so yeah, I guess, I don't know, is this, addressing the, the, the kind of… you know, and I, I,
Rick March: you know, like I said, I'm grateful that Dr. Dorsen saw a role for me in the Gary Project, and that the Gary Project was an important step in the direction that my career ultimately took.
Julie Stout: Led to and everything.
Julie Stout: So as we wrap up this… this section here, I wanted to give you the floor, this one last time to say anything else you want to about the Doris and Gary project, and I know you had some fun anecdotes, so if there's any anecdotes you want to share, before we, move on to the next topic, we can do that.
Rick March: Yeah, I think that the two most, you know, stunning ones were the ones I told you about, the turtle…
Rick March: about Gerson's, very memorable. …passing out in the… passing out in the phone booth.
Julie Stout: Yes, yeah.
Rick March: yeah, I don't think I have anything that comes close as a cool anecdote.
Julie Stout: That is totally fine, we can end this year, if you, if you feel.
Rick March: Yeah, I think this is… I think that… I think I was able… I think you gave me plenty of opportunity to, you know, shoot off my mouth, and I… I hope that, yeah, this research is… is worth it for you.
Julie Stout: Of course, I appreciate your insight and your perspective even more so. So I will end this here now, and then… yeah.
Julie Stout: Thank you again.
Rick March: Recordings are off, and just I want to ask you,